welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man
and this video we're breaking down some
of the insane details in thor ragnarok
throughout the entire mcu though has
arguably gone on the greatest dark
since his first film appearance back in
2011 he's changed from a selfish
self-centered character to one of
earth's mightiest defenders
i've loved watching him grow into a more
comedic character along with chris
hemsworth who's really made the role his
own
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing some of the best details in
the film
that we haven't really seen pointed out
in other videos there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the film yet then i
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a marvel breakdown
and please drop a thumbs up if you love
the god of thunder as much as we do
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
thor ragnarok
okay so the movie opens with the marvel
studios logo burning up in a scene that
is called the great prophecy
this burning of an institution is of
course mirrored in asgard which is
destroyed at the end by certain
though narrates his past and we learn
that this is the mission that he set out
on after the prophecy and age of ultron
he jokingly says that he fought a robot
which was of course ultron
and that he then settled on a quest to
find the infinity stones
which would have caused payoff in
infinity war unbeknownst to us
thanos was also on this quest at the
same time and the two crossed paths at
the end of the movie
the character comes face to face with
certa and the two talk about the fall of
asgard
thor busts out and he blasts his way
through certain army to the immigrant
song by led zeppelin
the asgardians become immigrants at the
end of the movie and end up settling on
earth in
endgame as the song plays we can hear
not only the phrase valhalla i'm coming
which is a reference to the asgardian
afterlife but also the lyrics will drive
our ships to the new lands
this is of course foreshadowing for the
ending in which thor sets out for earth
we cut to scourge trying to impress two
women and these
actually appear at the end of the movie
on the bridge which could be the thing
that reminds him of the life he used to
lead and may be the reason for his
triple cross of heller
we hear that heimdall was charged with
negligence by odin and that he fled
which is why scourges had to take his
place
this is the first clue that loki is now
owed in but another one comes in the
form of the theater which we can see
has been changed to look like loki's
helmet loki has a statue and a play
plays out in which matt damon acts as
loki
luke hemsworth plays thor and sam neil
plays odin
matt damon actually played loki in dogma
and this is a nice little reprisal of
the role for the mcu
loki apologizes for the tesseract which
is of course a call back to the avengers
and he also says sorry for turning thor
into a frog we've never saw this in the
mcu
but it could be a reference to the tv
show ultimate spider-man
in which thor is turned into one by loki
as loki dies we can also hear the music
that we heard during the funeral scene
for frigate in thor the dark world
though brings loki's facade crashing
down and he puts his hand behind loki's
head as he throws out malnier
thor says that nothing will stop it from
returning to his hand
but hella does later on and this line
subtly sets up just how much of a threat
she is
loki gives up and they head back to
earth to get out in however the all
people's home that he was left at is
being demolished
and we can see that this is called shady
acres which is the same one that ace
ventura visits to find information on
ray finkel
loki says it's not his fault as he can't
see the future because he's not a witch
in end game when thor returns to asgard
and sees friger
she says that she can tell he's from the
future because she was raised by witches
and therefore we know in the mcu that
they have the capability to do this
dora is also wearing a green t-shirt
over the top of a purple one
which are of course the hulk's colours
and comic books two girls appear and
asked to take a picture with him
and one of them is taylor hemsworth aka
chris's cousin
doctor strange sends loki through a
portal and leaves a card for thor who
arrives at blicker street to confront
the wizard
strange is actually wearing his yellow
gloves from the comics and though they
don't appear
later in the series it's nice that they
at least give a nod to them here
when they warp to a seated position we
can also see the restrained suit that's
strange used on cosilius and doctor
strange hanging on the wall behind them
strange offers thorty and this comes in
the same cup that the ancient one served
him tea in a comatage
he also plucks a strand of hair from
thor in order to create a spell to send
them directly to odin
this actually creates the triquetra rune
which is a symbol that is used
throughout asgard
it first appeared on thor's hammer all
the way back in door 1 when odin was
placing a spell upon it
in this movie it also appears in the
throne room and crypt on asgard and is
clearly tied to the family
loki unsheathes his knives and we can
actually also see hella do this in the
movie too
as well as thor all three draw their
swords in the same way
which could show that they were all
trained in a similar manner by odin as
children
they're sent to tonesburg which odin
remarks as being home
this would come to be the area that the
asgardians settle upon in endgame
but it also ties back to several other
mcu movies
centuries ago the frost giants arrived
on tonesburg in an attempt to conquer
midgard
but they were stopped by odin the area
was where the tesseract was hidden
and we saw it appear in captain america
the first avenger
it of course appears here and then as
the home for the resettled as guardians
in end game
in endgame we can also see a gladiator
walking around in the background
so it looks like they settled there with
the colony too before odin dies they all
sit down on a rock together
and odin and thor are on the same side
whereas we can see an uprising in the
rock symbolically separating loki from
the pair
this shows that he is an outcast from
them and the film is very much about
thor and loki repairing their
relationship in the wake of their
father's death
odin's death brings forth heller from
the underworld and it really kick-starts
the movie from this point
though always believed that he was the
firstborn but there were actually hints
that this wasn't the case throughout the
mcu
in age of ultron and his vision heimdall
calls him the first son of odin
but not the firstborn because he knows
that hella exists
we learn that she draws his strength
from asgard and we can see this in a
costume design
in tonesburg her clothing is heavily
torn but it repairs upon her arrival at
the kingdom
the antlers on her helmet also grow
longer the more time that she spends
there
and her outfit gets greener too this
showcases her
increase in strength and also that her
power is tied to the kingdom
thor throws his hammer at her and she
catches it we can actually see from the
way that the strap is defying gravity
and lifting outwardly that thor is
trying to pull it back himself
but she's so strong that he's unable to
we can also see in the exchange that
thor has a braid with black hair in it
the character threaded loki's hair with
his own in age of ultron and this is
carried across here
just too bad that stanley had to cut it
they travel back through the by frost to
which hella follows them
and this is how she is able to get to
asgard loki is knocked out first
and we learn in the film that he has
been on zakar for a while
we also discover from the grand master's
age that time moves differently there
which is how he is millions of years old
but doesn't look it
this also means that the hulk was likely
on the planet for years and years
rather than just the two that he missed
on earth hella kills two of the warriors
three and then the third one upon
arriving at asgard
siff doesn't get killed in this movie
and she has been rumored to be returning
in thor love and thunder
she also appeared in agents of shield so
yeah there's a lot of room for her to
come back
valkyrie shows up and captures thor and
we learn that her name is scrapper142
which is a reference to the incredible
hulk issue 142 in which she featured
she takes him to her ship and there are
hints that she's from asgard as thor
says he's the son of odin
and valkyrie replies with many apologies
your majesty
this shows that she is aware of odin and
therefore is from the kingdom
we also get a teaser beta ray bill as
one of the gladiator faces on the
champions tower
heller rips it up on asgard and we then
see thor moving through a tunnel on the
way to meet the grand master
the song pure imagination can be heard
in the background and this is a nod to
willy wonka in the chocolate factory
which also features that song and has a
weird tunnel scene in it
in that movie charlie enters as a
peasant and works his way up to being
the owner of the empire before blasting
off in a glass elevator
i might be reaching but this could be
seen as a similar journey to thor
who starts off as a gladiator on secor
before blasting into space at the end
after becoming the ruler of his kingdom
jeff goldblum does his best jeff
goldblum and we meet the grand master
this isn't actually the first time that
we've seen the character as he did
appear
dancing in the credits of the guardians
of the galaxy vol 2.
he takes thor to a party room and here
we see loki chatting with some people
he tells a story of how he let go which
is how he exits thor after letting go of
odin's staff
this symbolical letting go is of course
also how he let go of asgard
and became the villain that turned his
back on his people for the avengers
loki says he's never met thor in his
life and thor says that he's his brother
to which loki says adopted
which is of course a call back to the
avengers as well we meet korg
aka the best mcu character of all time
and he's played by taika watiti
corg does a rock paper scissors joke and
meek puts up his blades like scissors
kog steps on him at one point in the
movie so metaphorically
rock beats scissors he also says that he
wanted to start a revolution
but he didn't print enough pamphlets
pamphlets are made of paper
so i guess that paper did defeat rock
and rock did defeat scissors
that's that's a rock paper scissors joke
watiti also appears as a three-headed
gladiator
and there's a reference to his other
work what we do in the shadows
korg tries to give thor a fork which he
says would only be useful if you're
fighting three vampires
and that movie is about three vampires
we also see doug in the background who
is wearing green pants
and he has a purple upper body which is
the reverse of the hulk
hella goes to the throne room and
destroys the mural revealing a hidden
one which also has the triquetra within
it
when the mural is destroyed we can see
that there's a crack on thor's eye which
foreshadows his injury later on
we see hella explore owen's treasure
room and she says the infinity gauntlet
is fake
and another big giveaway is that thanos
wears the real one on his left hand
whereas this one is to be worn on the
right loki comes to visit thor
and i don't know if it's intentional but
i did get a lot of aping of the scene
and thought in which loki also comes to
visit the character
not only do we get a great stan lee
cameo but we can also see a bartender
that looks very similar to a celestial
i don't know if it's meant to be the
same but hey they they look alike
i worked in a ball once anyway it all
builds towards the hulk versus thor and
it's an incredible fight
we see the swords and sheathing as we
mentioned earlier and the two go head to
head
in the battle thor discovers that his
power comes from himself
and this of course ties into the end
after the battle thor and hulk
actually get to talk with one another
and they build a really really good
bromance
hulk typically refers to himself as hulk
like he says
hulk don't like this however here he
says i just get so angry
this is the only time that the character
uses the word i and it shows that he's
actually starting to gain a more human
side to his persona
this is further hammered home by the
foreshadowing of smarthulk
which happens when banner looks at
footage of the hulk in the quinjet
and his face lines up with the beast
this hints that the best way to handle
everything is to meld their
personalities together
and this of course comes to fruition and
endgame we can also see that there's a
bull within hulk's sleeping quarters
and we can see that he's thrown it so
many times at the wall that it's
stripped away the paint
in the background of a scene you may
also notice that a ship flies up to a
wormhole and it's destroyed by falling
debris
though goes back to the quinjet and his
password is point break
which is what stark called him in the
avengers bruce finally comes out of the
hulk
and when you think about it this guy has
pretty much gone from the events of age
of ultron directly to this
infinity war happens not too long after
so yeah
not a good week for him they team up
with valkyrie who has loki chained up
thor throws a can of his head to check
that he's real and he hits him
square in the buns later in the film
after losing his eye
he tries to throw a can at him once more
but loki catches it
it would have missed anyway which shows
that thor losing his eye has messed with
his perception of depth
thor also pockets valkyrie's electronic
subduer which he later uses on loki
thor and cole leaves the car korg starts
his revolution
and they return to asgard to take down
heller when heller and thor come face to
face
they actually say a line to one another
that was delivered by odin in the first
thor movie
that quote is a wise king never seeks
out war
but must always be ready for it thor
says the opening part of this
which hella finishes showing that odin
raised them similarly
hulk fights fenrir and we can also see
on his chest that there's a score from
when the abomination stabbed him
all the way back in the incredible hulk
banner also jumps out the ship
similar to how he jumps out of the plane
at the end of that movie but here
his ball is used a lot more for comedic
effect though embraces his power
and he goes all out he does it as slam i
i want to call it a thunder slam but i
don't know anyway
he does this and it really throws back
the forces of his sister
we can see how far this move has come in
infinity war when he completely wrecked
shop after landing on wakanda
this was the best scene of all time i
don't care what anyone says
it still makes me want to smash stuff up
thor at one point
actually swings swords around when
fighting the undead and he holds them by
the blade
the way that the handle is on them
almost in some ways looks like a hammer
and it shows that he's most comfortable
with his fighting style thought if he
teller
who brings the prophecy of ragnarok to
fruition thor sets sail into the stars
with the asgardians and we can actually
see when he sits on the throne that as
loki approaches him
hulk makes a fist showing that the
character is still ready to slam him
into the ground at any second
thor asks where they should head to korg
says that meek's alive
and thank god and thor says earth it is
which is where the group end up in game
though they would have
something bad happen along the way which
is thanos who we see teased in the
post-credits scene
however at the start of infinity war we
can see that the ship they're in splits
off into two
as typical of thanos he let half live
and kill the other half
and this half of the ship likely flew to
earth as that was supposed to be their
destination
as we know from endgame korg valkyrie
and meek were on the planet
and that is how they survived they got
their destination from thor
and in a way it sort of brings
everything full circle
ending the film and tying it in
perfectly with the next
and that's our list obviously i'd love
to hear what easter eggs were your
favorite and if we missed any
comment below and let us know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out some of the
insane details that we noticed in
avengers end game
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition yt
or click the discord link in the
description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with heavy spoilers so hopefully we
see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thank you for taking the
time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you